[Music]
a huge battle over voting taking center
stage in america
a fear-mongering joe biden smearing
republicans is racist
and claiming democracy in america is
under siege over states like texas
trying to pass election integrity laws
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting and we're going to
challenge it vigorously
are you on the side of truth or lies
fact or fiction
justice or injustice democracy or
autocracy
that's what it's coming down to stand up
for god's sake
and help prevent this concerted effort
to undermine our elections
and the sacred right to vote have you no
shame
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war joe biden's also
calling for a federal
takeover of elections and is promising
to use his department of justice to go
after the states now keep in mind
that while the president spews that kind
of rhetoric liberal fact checkers have
found these republican bills
actually expand voting hours but those
facts don't matter to liberals in texas
a group of show voting democrats just
skipping town
in order to block republicans there from
passing these new voting bills
they're fashioning themselves as
political martyrs who of course fled to
washington d.c on a pair
of private jets without face masks and a
case of beer
and while these democrats soak up
attention texas governor greg abbott's
promising to arrest them
when they return that is not the way
that texas
texans do things i will continue calling
special session after special session
because overtime is going to continue
until they step up to vote once they
step back into the state of texas
that will be arrested and brought to the
texas capitol and we will be conducting
business
so greg you think they're going to slap
the cuffs on these fleeing democrats or
not
you know at first i was going to talk
about that but
the joe what joe said today just upsets
me i mean he is
a pathological shameless liar
he he ran on being a unifier
and all he does is bank on racial
discontent right he's like
comparing this bill to the kkk into jim
crow it's like
all he does is foment racial conflict
and he's making
he claims that he's making a moral case
for voting rights as if there are no
voting rights
every american has the right to vote
except the left's favorite voting blocs
which are violent felons illegal
immigrants and the dead
my theory is there's only one
possibility of a true
zombie uprising and it's if corpses
found out that they were voted for joe
biden
but why the only republicans democrats
know of
are evil it started with ronald reagan
ronald reagan was supposed to be the
worst
right he was hitler then you got george
bush he was you know warmonger
then you had the other george bush he
was a warmonger then you had john mccain
warmonger then you had mitt romney was
going to put everybody back in chains
right then we're supposed to get the
biggest greatest
existential risk in history out of
donald trump
and now we're sold that's a lie because
he's gone
and now this is a bigger existential
risk than donald trump
this is the worst thing since the civil
war
i'm beginning to think they're
exaggerating
what gives you that i don't know i'm
just looking forward to the next
existential risk gene i looked through
the entire texas voting bill today and
there is not
one thing in there that restricts voting
not
one thing there isn't one thing in there
that restricts voting and if you
if you think about it they haven't
brought one person before you to tell
you
that this person was not able to vote
because of this
in fact what they want to do is remember
when they expanded everything because it
was a pandemic
they want to expand the pandemic they
want to keep the pandemic voting and
they want to expand that
and you know what really makes me crazy
and what makes me crazy is you have
these texas legislators
who make a decision that they're going
to go to washington d.c i mean it's such
an embarrassment to texans i mean
i know a lot of people from texas i love
a lot of people in texas
okay the one thing they don't do is cut
and run
the one thing they don't do is run to
daddy in washington say daddy help us we
we don't want to do our job we want to
federalize the election law who gave you
that right get back to work
people voted for you to work on
legislation you tried to stop the
regular session they couldn't get any
things passed they know how to do it
and now they're doing it for the special
sessions these people are an
embarrassment look at them they look
like they're going to camp
and i guarantee you there's miller light
on that there is miller light
because they probably had to pay for
that they didn't have to pay for the
plane
so they got a charter plane but when
they had to buy the beer
killer liked the plane oh obviously the
taxpayers
all right so how does it look right now
the democrats fleeing to washington and
i believe kamala harris is going to be
meeting with these fleeing democrats
i don't know when but we will cover it
here on the show
it can't look good i don't know who paid
for that plane soros
soros i think jack when you think about
judge i think you raise excellent points
and everyone's raised the right points
i like you this is the first time you've
been together
keep your hands off it i'm sorry
we've had that problem before we have to
ask the question what is what do we want
when we have an election now
to your point we during the pandemic we
made accommodations to make it easier
for people to vote
i happen to think what you won in the
election and i've run in five elections
uh
six i lost one i wish we could have come
back and found more people to vote and
make some of the claims that former
president trump is making but i lost the
election
i wanted more people to vote and they
didn't more people voted this time and
it just turns out that democrats won
this time
now if we have a set of systems in place
to create that and to encourage that and
to validate that going forward
i think we should now politics too much
theater traveling to dc i get the
politics i get the theater of the
politics
we all engage a little of that to make
our point but i remind everybody
60 federal and state courts denied these
claims there's been more scrutiny around
this presidential race
look the guy that i wanted to win won
and i'm thankful
had he lost i would have accepted it and
moved on i think at some point the body
politic needs to accept
that there was an election president
biden won and if we are serious about
more people voting
let's put efforts forward and changes to
election laws that allow more people to
vote and not make it harder for people
to vote and what are the democrats
they believe they believe they're making
it harder for people let me ask you a
specific question
where in the texas bill does it make it
harder for people to vote so
i'd say two things yeah i said answer
your question number one we roll back
some of the pandemic
uh accommodations that were made to help
more people make it easier to vote like
what what are they rolling back and what
does it do to make it harder
for people to vote 24-hour voting in uh
houston it wasn't supposed to be allowed
and they did it in the 20s so there's
one thing look i don't know we can we
can go line by line on the bill but
there's no doubt
there are efforts that are different for
the 20 20 22 and 24 election if this
passes but actually if it is
so if if you're saying they're rolling
back that's actually not true because
they're
adding more time to vote maybe they took
away the 24 hour yeah they took away
way more hours earlier like i think
we're also
i think some i think i'm not saying it's
not a serious topic but i think it's
actually these this is to be ridiculed
and laughed at
um because okay if nothing passes
the state reverts back to pre-2020 oh
okay
and so if that's somebody read the
package then the democrats are actually
for restrictions because it would be
pre-2020 there actually are new things
in here
another point the supreme court just
ruled was it last week or the week
before
that not a single person could be shown
to have been harmed in arizona
um when it came to voting restrictions
and so the supreme court said no if you
can't show somebody
somebody actual person has been harmed
when you can't that was your point there
right but also
the texas democrats really didn't think
this through they made arrangements for
private jets
hotel rooms they scheduled their tv
interviews but they did not have a
communications meeting
they have simply no message at all so
they end up doing step one get on a
plane
get some beer take a lot of selfies step
two
leave that blank let's fill that in
later and step three
win the fight they are trying to play
power politics with no power
no there's no strategy they need a mitch
mcconnell who can calmly say
this is the goal that we want to get to
this is what we're going to be able to
do and then you message it and work
it's work backwards now these guys are
going to they're like well we're going
to stay in dc for
an indeterminate period oh please send
more money so that we can stay in the
hotel
and they're definitely making money off
of this they're fundraising like crazy
where are they
26 states exactly where are their
matches not only that but they're going
to be there for 26 days
yeah and that's that's because that's
when the this special session is ending
they're not going back before 20 who's
paying for this hotel
democrat socialist of america
yeah harold yeah that was a question
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else